zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu
heute live da sind wir in einer kamera
dann nehme ich die und ihrem leid stehen
zu aktuellen ereignissen und es ist
natürlich immer noch das ereignis der
letzten 24 stunden der sturm auf das
kapitol in washington das war ein
ziemlich verstörende bilder die gestern
abend dazu uns kamen gab mittlerweile
vor genau fast 24 stunden ging das los
vier stunden lang hielten hunderte
menschen das capitol besetzt um singles
waren teilweise drin bis im senat und
erst dann konnte die situation langsam
wieder unter kontrolle gebracht werden
vier menschen sind bei den unruhen ums
leben gekommen der schock sitzt tief in
amerika aber auch in europa und in
deutschland wird darüber diskutiert wie
es dazu kommen konnte dass möchte ich
heute versuchen zu klären einmal meinen
kollegen claus kleber bei mir im studio
und langjähriger amerika korrespondent
und amerika kenner außerdem meiner
kollegin alicia jungen die ist für uns
vor ort in washington und wird uns über
die lage in den usa berichten und später
richtig mit unserer fakten checken julia
klaus sprechen die hat nämlich
recherchiert was das eigentlich für
leute waren die gestern sich dort am und
im capitol getummelt haben fragen
kommentare wie immer sehr gern in die
dafür vorgesehenen kommentarspalten oder
per e mail an zdf heute.de zdf.de falls
sie in der app zu gucken aber wir fangen
erst mal bei meinem kollegen klaus an
was lange in amerika hast eine starke
verbindung zu dem land gekämpft das land
und die leute was geht er jetzt 24
stunden nach denen das dort begonnen hat
durch den kopf immer noch die das
erstaunen und auch die verzweiflung über
gestern dieses gefühl verdammt nochmal
jetzt passiert ist doch noch wenige
stunden vorher habe ich mit einem
amerikanischen freund korrespondiert und
er hat gesagt na deine düstersten
prognosen scheinen ja nicht wahr zu
werden jetzt läuft als heute im kongress
und ich schrieb zurück ja ich habe mich
geirrt aber ich bin glücklich darüber
und dann 20 uhr 15 oder so
kamen so die ersten twitter geschichten
und ich dachte das geht aber los ihr
wart super sofort auf dem sender damit
und also auf eurem digitalen sender was
zählt und das hat mich die ganze nacht
wach gehalten ich habe bin ich bin
glaube ich heute morgen um fünf ins bett
gegangen weil jetzt ist gerade jetzt
muss auch mal hierher schlafen und es
war kein nicht diese professionelle
befriedigung wie man bei solchen dingen
spürt sondern einfach nur verzweiflung
und trauer und kann nicht wahr sein
unglauben job hat er seine anhänger
immer wieder aufgewickelt aufgehetzt
eigentlich die letzten jahr sechs jahre
muss man sagen und die rede gestern vor
dem weißen haus die war ja nicht
zufällig parallel zu der debatte im
kongress
du hast jetzt gerade schon gesagt du
hattest düstere vorahnungen hätte man
das nicht kommen sehen können
die rede habe ich gar nicht verfolgt in
dem moment ich wusste ja hat vor dorthin
zu kommen ich war auch auf der autobahn
unterwegs und konnte nicht jetzt so
dinge verfolgen und dann redet dieser
mann wirklich so dass er am ende sagt
geht jetzt zum kapitol und verhindert
das schlimmste was uns am liebsten kann
unmöglich also dass ein amerikanischer
präsident zum sturm auf ein anderes
verfassungsorgan ruft das hat es die
letzten 230 jahre dich gegeben und
irgendwann glaubt man ja mal dann gibt
es das auch nicht mehr aber trump hat
auch jetzt auf dieser zielgeraden seiner
präsidentschaft noch mal alle
historischen beispiele gerissen wir
schalten meiner kolleginnen oder unserer
kollegin alice washington
die ist dort klingt ein bisschen im
detail dem hintergrund dass es dadurch
nicht
in diesen minuten wird hier gerade vor
dem kapitol ein trauen errichtet und ich
drehe euch mal kurz ein bisschen mit
ihrem mit mir mit dann könnt ihr sehen
passiert jetzt auch hier hinter mir also
rund um das kapitol die national guard
stationiert ist und quasi das gelände
bewacht dieser zaun
nehmen könnt also dieser schwarze zahlen
er ist neu der wird gerade in diesen
minuten aufgebaut und auch eben die
präsenz der der national guard ist jetzt
also neu weil sie war gestern als es
dann also zu diesem sturm auf das
kapital kam noch nicht da
dazu können wir später auch namen wie es
entsprechen werden wir auf jeden fall
tun weil da gibt es große fragezeichen
wie ist denn die lage jetzt gerade vor
ort das sieht es relativ ruhig und
entspannt außen zu sagen jetzt gerade
natürlich ist es ruhig und entspannt
aber jetzt bei diesem aufgebot hier
wirklich an sicherheitskräften das eben
gestern also um dieselbe uhrzeit ja noch
nicht da war ist jetzt auch hier im
prinzip gar nicht mehr möglich auf das
gelände zu kommen
das ist also hier jetzt weitere 90
abgesperrt wer weiß für wie lange
also vermutlich natürlich auch bis nach
der inauguration weil das was man
gestern ja auch gesehen hat ist wirklich
wie einfach es war zuvor in des kapitals
auf das gelände einzudringen und dann
selbst sogar in das gebäude einzudringen
und heute ist jetzt also hier zur stunde
alles ruhig und friedlich anders als
gestern die stimmung war gestern
wirklich extrem aggressiv auch gegenüber
journalisten das ist haben wir gesehen
also da ist auch unser kamerateam
angegriffen worden
wir haben noch bilder gesehen
tatsächlich von einem jungen mann der
mit dem zdf mikrofon posierte unser
kollege mrt wissen muss es ist ein
sicherheit bringen was heißt das jetzt
für eure arbeit
maschinen hast du da sorgen dass sich
wirklich etwas passiert
es ist tatsächlich so dass wir also
relativ lange wir hier sehr unsere
unbehelligt arbeiten konnten weil wir
als ausländische medien auch da gibt es
irgendwie ein bisschen ihr habt es in
weniger kritisch beäugt wurden und das
war also wirklich gestern anders da
wurde ihm wurden hier einfach medien
grundsätzlich ganz egal also angegriffen
wie du richtig gesagt hat unser
equipment wurde zerstört und entwendet
und an den den an den wänden des
kapitols steht mörder oder wurde
reingeritten eine tür mörder der media
also gestern hat sich wirklich noch mal
eine ganz eine ganz besondere wut und
hass gegenüber also hier der politik
aber auch gegenüber den medien entladen
also gestern war das wirklich sehr sehr
gefährlich auch für die kolleginnen und
kollegen und wie das jetzt für die
zukunft was das für uns bedeutet dass
tatsächlich dass wir wirklich viel mehr
noch auf unsere sicherheit gucken müssen
als wir das zu forschen mussten
wie geht es da schon ja die ersten
fragen genau in diese richtung wie
konnte das überhaupt passieren hier
fragte wieso auf youtube die konnte es
möglich sein überhaupt in dieser form um
das kapitol vorzudringen um klaus du
warst ja auch schon sehr häufig dort und
hat auch getwittert gestern die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind eigentlich
unglaublich hoch sonntag also sie sind
nicht so hoch direkt an den türen durch
die gestern auch die eindringlinge
reingekommen sind soweit sie nicht
durchs fenster gestiegen sind aber für
normalbürger gibt es da wo alice jetzt
steht gibt es auf der anderen seite ein
einen ganzen unterirdischen komplex
durch den normale visitors reinkommen
und das ist völlig unmöglich da jetzt
mit zum beispiel mit schusswaffen was ja
der fall war es dann ins kapitol zu
kommen und die kapo police ist also
sowas von pedantisch und genau mit den
vorschriften dass selbst ein schritt auf
die falsche richtung dann oft mit wüsten
beschimpfungen endet und ich kann sie
hier gleich wieder rausschmeißen also da
lernt man die linie genau einzuhalten
das gestern war völlig die waren völlig
überrannt wir waren ohne chance das
sieht man ja auch an den bildern
man versteht auch weshalb die
zurückweichen bei weichen mussten
sie hatten weder die zahlen noch die
ausrüstung um mit zöllner
herausforderung fertig zu werden und die
die eingedrungen sind haben sich ja dann
so spaziergehen
wir haben ja gar nichts anderes gemacht
als 11
[Musik]
die vorschauen tatsächlich setzt sich
jetzt dass ich sogar eine trampolin es
waren drei autos sind wir gerade gesehen
haben sind drei autos mit tram fans und
pfannen die jetzt hier also um das
gebäude herum gefahren sind es waren nur
drei ich dachte jetzt auch gerade
vielleicht kommen noch mehr aber es war
tatsächlich nur drei hupende autos mit
trump fahnen und offensichtlich also
tram fans die immer noch zu ihm halten
ja also die lassen sich tatsächlich von
den ereignissen nicht einstehen dass aus
dieser wie wird denn das jetzt in den
usa diskutiert also es gibt ja die
capital police die ist zuständig für das
capitol für die eigene einheit
es gibt natürlich die polizei der stadt
die rechtfertigen dass das das zuerst
verlieren könnte der chef der capital
profis also die ja tatsächlich genau für
eben den schutz dieses gebäudes
verantwortlich ist und zuständig ist der
hat sich jetzt ganz klar natürlich also
von den menschen und von den ereignissen
von denen also den menschen die
eingedrungen sind distanziert
nichtsdestotrotz bleibt die frage also
wieso waren denn so wenige beamte
beamtinnen vor ort weil das haben wir
ganz klar auf den videos gesehen sie
waren tatsächlich zu wenige und das gilt
es jetzt aufzuarbeiten
und da ist aber tatsächlich heute jetzt
zur stunde noch nicht ganz klar warum
sie denn in so einer geringen zahlen
wirklich nur vor ort waren was aber eben
auch problematisch gesehen wird ich habe
es am anfang eher angesprochen ist dass
die national guard eben nicht
rechtzeitig da war sondern eben jetzt
heute also im sie kamen gestern also
erst nach dem quasi der große aufmarsch
er schon passiert ist kamen sie erst in
der stadt an und das wird hier sehr sehr
kritisch gesehen und da gibt es auf eben
also eine eine rede davon diskussionen
davon dass auch die national guard gar
nicht von donald trump selber dann
beordert wurde sondern dass das ein
fenster und da gibt es eben jetzt im
moment eine diskussion darüber und das
wird sehr sehr kritisch gesehen
so sind wir einschätzen warum das so
passiert und ich erlebe jetzt wie in
washington ein spiel gespielt wird das
nicht unheimlich erinnert an die zeit
nach nine eleven
da war auch die große frage wie kann das
sein dass ein dutzend todespiloten ist
in amerika selber ausbilden lassen und
dann
gleich mehrere verschiedene
cover
die allgemeinen ziele zeige immer die an
sichtlich
vor dem hintergrund der ergebnisse
sie verstärken sondern an der zukunft
hoffe ich die im moment ist es gerade
wohl das fbi das die journalistin
füttert und sagt wir haben gewarnt
die anderen haben das blockiert da
werden die anderen sich jetzt
revanchieren und wahrscheinlich
irgendwelche anderen sachen durch
stecken
es ist aber auf jeden fall erkennen das
ist ein riesen chaos gab zwischen fbi
national guard stadtverwaltung capitol
das ja auch teilweise von
kontrolliert wird auf der seite 51 der
rielle chef der sicherheit im capitol
ist abhängig von politischen strömungen
und ganz offensichtlich ist nicht
genügend vorbereitet worden
und dass der unterschied zu den löwen
die haben im verborgenen gearbeitet dass
man die todespiloten nicht entdeckt hat
dass kann man nachträglich verstehen
dass man nicht gesehen hat was auf
diesen ganzen websites los war vorher
dass man die rede des eigenen
präsidenten ich hörte er sagt wir
sterben jetzt das capitol und vorher
twittert es wird eine wilde zeit kommt
nach washington und nimmt daran teil
dass man das alles ignoriert hat ist
jenseits dessen was man verstehen
das ist ein sehr gutes stichwort für
unseren kleinen ein spieler den wir
vorbereitet haben denn präsident ram hat
in den letzten wochen und monaten jedoch
immer wieder man muss fast sagen
agitiert zumindest mit sehr deutlichen
worten immer wieder klar gemacht was
passieren wird wenn er nicht gewählt
wird bzw was nicht passieren wird
mein kollege heiko kunzmann hat dass man
uns zusammengefasst
auch die bilder entschuldigung ich
kriegsgericht ausbau gesagt wir wollten
erst mal noch gucken wie es gestern aus
gesehen hat das habe ich ein bisschen
unterschlagen tut mir leid also
tatsächlich wir schauen auch mal an was
da gestern passiert ist weil diese
bilder sind doch sehr sehr eindrücklich
gewesen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit den tropfen so also wir haben auch
hier eine muntere diskussion bei uns
online natürlich einmal einmal die
öffentliche kritik dass wir beide keine
masken tragen die versuchen abstand
einzuhalten die man einhalten muss in
dieser zeit das sind ungefähr aber in
der frage an dich klaus nochmal zu der
bedrohungen gegenüber journalisten gab
es hier vorn
david cohen per mail weil gestern ja
auch ausrüstung von unserem zerstört
wurde kannst du dich an eine
vergleichbare situation in den usa
erinnern
nein nein es gibt in vielen beziehungen
keine vergleichbare situation bei rodney
king reihe in los angeles als auf jedem
weißen eingeschlagen wurde für eine
nacht da war ich mittendrin und da habe
ich mich unwohl gefühlt aber da ging es
ja nicht um staatliche organe und es
ging auch nicht um eine politische
entscheidung in der mitte der hauptstadt
und da habe ich keine vergleichbaren
situationen den kopf
jedenfalls nicht im reichsten land der
welt wieso hast du solche situationen
schon erlebt dass er jetzt in deiner
arbeit du bist ja schon ein paar monate
in den usa dass du dich bedroht gefühlt
hast kannst du die frage noch mal
stellen hat dass ich mich bedroht
gefühlt habe noch nie ich eher weniger
aber das ist vielleicht nehme ich jetzt
der der spannende punkt also was ganz
viele
besonders schwarze menschen in diesem
land sagen ist und was ich auch also
selbst miterlebt und den ganzen sommer
über bei den protesten gegen
polizeigewalt und gegen rassismus ist
das tatsächlich schwarze menschen in
diesem land ganz anders behandelt werden
und behandelt worden sind im sommer als
das jetzt hier gestern der fall weit
also diese menschen die da gestern ins
kapitol reingegangen sind der grosse
grosse teil von ihnen waren weiß und die
waren sich sehr sehr sicher dass ihnen
nichts passieren wird wenn sie da jetzt
rein gehen dass ihnen nichts schlimmeres
passieren wird es gibt ganz viele
schwarze menschen in diesem land die
sagen ein schwarzer hätte niemals lebend
es rein und wieder raus geschafft auf
den stuhl im kapitol wo zuvor noch mit
mike pence saß oder in das büro von
nancy pelosi
also das ist jetzt hier auch gerade noch
mal eine große diskussion in großer
aufschrei in diesem land weil wir
erinnern uns daran bei den protesten im
sommer gegen rassismus und polizeigewalt
wurden demonstrierende gewaltsam mit mit
tränengas von der straße geräumt als
präsident für ein fototermin die
straßenseite des weißen hauses
gewechselt hat also das ist hier jetzt
auch noch
eine sehr große debatte und da muss viel
aufgearbeitet werden
da stellt sich die frage klaus gibt es
hat tatsächlich ja wird dann mit
zweierlei maß gemessen und 8 ist eine
nähe der polizei auch zu zu rechten
gruppen die die polizei in washington
spielt eine besondere rolle die ist die
polizei in einer stadt die mehrheitlich
schwarz ist auch die polizei selbst ist
mehrheitlich schwarz das würde ich jetzt
nicht verallgemeinert für das land
leider denn die beziehungen dort in
washington sind besser und die
bürgermeisterin legt auch großen wert
darauf dass die besser sind aber ich
kann nur bestätigen was ehrlich gesagt
das ist nichts neues das war schon immer
so dass man in der begegnung mit der
polizei wesentlich besser dran war wenn
man weiß aber selbst wenn mit schwarzem
polizisten zu tun und diese dass das
jetzt noch mal so einen richtigen boost
bekommen hat durch den vergleich mit
saint john's kirche damals als niedrig
fliegende helikopter friedliche
demonstranten auseinandergetrieben haben
und dieses mal wo militante truppen
ungehindert ins kapitol spazieren also
krasser kann man das gar nicht
inszenieren
und das macht die ganzen bunten noch mal
auf dieses fatalen jahres 2009 10
das insgesamt ja auch für das verhältnis
der rassen oder der ethnien in den usa
ein verheerendes jahr aber weil immer
die falschen signale aus dem weißen haus
kommen ich habe ja auch eine anmerkung
von
henry auf youtube hat doch gesagt die
sicherheitskräfte sind auf eurer seite
wen wundert's da dass die so einfach ein
gekommen sind und das ist der zeitpunkt
uns ja die trank zitate der letzten
wochen an zu hören wie er tatsächlich
dort ja agitiert was haltet euch zurück
und haltet euch bereit ich sage jemand
muss etwas tun gegen antifa und die
linken
wenn man die legalen stimmen zählt
gewinne ich mit leichtigkeit wenn man
die illegalen stimmen zählt können sie
versuchen uns die wahl zu stellen
wir wollen nicht dass unser wahlsieg
gestohlen wird von den radikalen linken
das tun sie wir werden niemals aufgeben
lasst uns die pennsylvania avenue
herunter marschieren
ja also das ist ein ganz klarer aufruf
gewesen das capitol ja wenn ich
zustimmen doch zumindest zu belagern
al issawi werden diese ereignisse usa
heute diskutiert wird das genannt
aufstand randale contest
es wird tatsächlich also ja in einer art
aufstand eine ein jahr in eine stürmung
des weißen haus schon genannt weniger
ein foto tatsächlich aber ja ein
aufstand in jedem falle
und das interessante ist ja vielleicht
auf werden ja gerade die zitate von
trump auch noch mal gehört also gerade
als auch wer zu den kreis sicher gewandt
hat in der debatte und gesagt hatte
haltet euch bereit
man kann sagen ja sie haben sich bereit
gehalten und sie waren hier auch in der
stadt und sie waren auch nicht zum
ersten mal in der stadt also auch bei
den anderen stoppte stil so nennen die
sich ja diese proteste für eben donald
trump und quasi gegen gegen den sieg
beiden da waren immer schon hier auch
preuß sogenannte brautpreis also eine
einem eine gewaltbereite gruppe hier in
der stadt und die waren auch gestern
wieder da und die haben an sich auch
tatsächlich schon im vorfeld auf
sozialen plattformen wie beispielsweise
banner organisiert also da war schon
relativ klar im vorfeld wer hier in
dieser stadt kommen wird und dass das
nicht nur familien mit kindern sein
werden sondern durchaus menschen die
eben hier auch zu allen bereit sind
hier gibt es im kommentar der passt dazu
auf youtube von m-broker da wird von
staatsstreich gesprochen was kompletter
unsinn ist wie hätte das denn
weitergehen sollen das muss es einen
plan geben
die usa haben 50 einzelstaaten überall
sonst ist nichts passiert
für einen staatsstreich sieht anders aus
ich glaube dass überall sonst nichts
passiert ist kann sie nichts wirklich
gesagt werden ich habe zumindest auch
bilder gesehen dass der die residenzen
von überhören belagert wurden teilweise
aber klaus würdest du das ein
staatsstreich nennen oder einen aufstand
oder das herz seiner einschätzung es
hätte einer werden ich glaube nicht dass
das ein staatsstreich war denn die
strategische überlegung die ja auch drei
vier fünf schritte nach vorne gehen
müsste um so etwas zu kastrieren das ist
nicht am start
aber er liebt das dinge durcheinander zu
bringen ein trümmer zu schlagen in die
luft zu werfen und dann mal zu gucken
wie die sache wieder runterkommt ob er
nicht dann dort durch diese bruchstücke
irgendeinen weg findet der ihn zwei drei
schritte näher an sein ziel führend und
sein ziel ist er eindeutig die macht
nicht abgeben zu müssen
anschober nun hätte es ja gestern auch
sein können und in der fantasie von
trump ist es durchaus denkbar dass hat
er mehrfach angedeutet
dass auch in anderen staaten plötzlich
andere leute in die kapitale ihrer
hauptstelle gehen
nach dem motto was in washington geht
wird ja wohl in minnesota auch möglich
sein
und dann und dann eine situation
entsteht wo ein nationaler notstand ist
wo rechnet orten und zusammenbrechen
nicht nur ein paar hundert schritte um
das kapitol sondern im ganzen land und
dann muss ja jemand kraftvoll das land
führen und durch diese krise führen und
open ended und wer so könnt ihr das denn
anderer sein als donald trump wer weiß
vielleicht geht diesen die richtung
alles was er tun muss es eine kleine
rede halten in der zum schluss gesagt
wird wir laufen jetzt zum kapitol und
sich dann zurück zu lehnen im openoffice
und bis hin zu twittern und zu gucken
wie es so läuft und es ist zweifellos
nicht in richtung staatsstreich gelaufen
dass das potenzial nie existiert hat
jedenfalls in der fantasie von trump
würde ich niemals sagen das war durchaus
ein möglicher ausgang des tages und sehr
vernünftige vorsichtige fortschrittliche
leute in der usa glauben dass das
tatsächlich der plan gewesen ist soweit
man das einplanen nennt will wenn man
sagt ich werde jetzt mal alles in die
luft gepustet
alisa welche konsequenzen es gerade in
den usa aus dem gestrigen tag
du hast mich gefragt welche konsequenzen
es gibt wirklich weil es ist ein
bisschen lauter
ja es wird jetzt hier verschiedenste das
diskutiert tatsächlich also man ist
jetzt noch nicht dabei die eine
konsequenz
es ziehen aber es gibt verschiedene
debatten und zwar gibt es hier stimmen
die laut werden natürlich besonders viel
auf demokratischer seite aber nicht nur
und es ist interessant die sagen dass
der präsident noch jetzt die letzten
tage in seinem amt entfernt werden soll
das ist nicht so einfach aber da gibt es
gedankenspiele die einen sprechen von
einem amtsenthebungsverfahren und/oder
fordern dass und andere ansprechen von
einem zusatzartikel 25 der angewendet
werden soll
der quasi dazu führen könnte dass mike
pence die geschäfte dann führt bis also
joe biden hier hier einst amt eingeführt
wird also darüber wird gerade hitzig
diskutiert weil viele sagen sie sind
nicht dafür dass trump also jetzt
wirklich noch diese letzten paar tage
bis zum 20
im amt bleibt in dieser mächtigsten
positionen des landes alice auf vielen
dank für deine einschätzung heute aus
den usa und für die bilder das sieht das
jetzt nicht so aus als ob das telefon
zumindest die nächsten wochen nicht
gemacht wird sind die das gewissen zwei
wochen dann ist an die amtseinführung
konto bei
ja noch aus deutschland gab es viele
reaktionen auf die gestrigen tabelle an
wie auch immer man das nennen möchte
unter anderem vom bundespräsidenten
unter bundestag
haben diese bilder wütend und auch
traurig gemacht und ich bedauere sehr
dass präsident trump seine niederlage
seit november nicht eingestanden hat und
auch gestern die da nicht
zweifel am wahlausgang wurden geschürt
und das hat die atmosphäre dafür
bereitet dass die ereignisse der nacht
erst möglich gemacht hat diese szenen
die wir gesehen haben
sie sind das ergebnis von lügen und noch
mehr lügen von spalte reihe und
demokratie verachtung von hass und hetze
auch von allerhöchster stelle
das ist eine historische zäsur für die
vereinigten staaten und das ist ein
angriff auf die liberale demokratie
überhaupt
ja da ist die große frage wer hat denn
eigentlich tatsächlich dort die liberale
demokratie angegriffen
das hat meine kollegin julia klaus für
uns versucht herauszufinden hat sich die
halbe nacht um die ohren geschlagen und
hat das netz durchforstet julia was hast
du herausgefunden
ja also ich hab versucht von deutschland
aus wie gesagt ich habe fernseher
geschaut ich hab doch erfolgt die
sozialen medien und wollte herausfinden
wer da genau bestimmt hat also welche
gruppen und hab da versucht eine ein
grenzen zu ziehen zum teil gibt es da
eben überschneidung also zum einen was
wir gesehen haben oder was man sagen
kann ist dass verschwörungs gläubige in
washington auf jeden fall war ganz
prominent vertreten ist diese you in on
der verschwörungs mythos davon
da ist auch ein
prominente in den senat sogar
eingedrungen ich weiß nicht ob ihr das
bild zeigen können ich habe das bild
hier vorliegen das ist dieser büffel man
würde ich ihnen jetzt mal nennen
kyu won schamane okay ist interessant
weil der mann sieht nicht aus wie ein
schamane sondern die und weißer also
erträgt diese hörnern auf dem oberkörper
frei und er ist tatsächlich in die stadt
eingedrungen
auf das tattoo komme ich gleich zu
sprechen
sein name ist in charlie und im ersten
bekannt über den anhänger und hat es
tatsächlich geschafft dort einzudringen
interessant ist tatsächlich dieses
dieses tattoo weil es den sogenannten
bhutans knoten zeigt das ist ein
germanisches symbol was aber auch in der
neonazi szene verwendet wird vielleicht
kann ich noch ganz kurz erklären was
keen on heißt ich weiß das ist auch also
ist auch eine verschwörungstheorie die
auch in deutschland verbreitet ist und
weil eben auch in den usa ein anhänger
glauben dass es einen tiefen staat gibt
also eine elite eine geheim regierende
elite die kinder entführt der blut
trinkt um sich damit zu verjüngen und
das donald trump gegend also gegen diese
intern kämpfen würde und dass die
gesellschaft oder die politik deswegen
eben auch dann etwas entfernen möchte so
eben diese dieser verschwörungs
erzählung von turn on und diesen an
diesen prominenten anhänger hat er eben
eingedrungen ist als weitere gruppe hab
dich auf jeden fall kann man den
überbegriff rechtsextreme dafür
verwenden heraus ziehen würde ich dort
mal die braut balls da war ja auch eben
schon bei erließ die rede von das ist
eben eine militante rechtsextreme
organisation die als sehr gewaltbereit
eingestuft wird die sind auch immer sehr
martialisch gekleidet mit diesen
schusssicheren westen ich weiß ich habe
da vielleicht auch noch das bild zeigen
kannst ich habe hier das bild jetzt mal
von von dem bärtigen mann der das camp
auschwitz diesen camps pullover an hat
was die männer gekränkt ein hologramm
relativierung ist ne das ist jetzt die
holocaust relativierung also vielleicht
gewährt mit dem partner abschließender
wurde jetzt auch schon was zugesagt
als weitere gruppe ist auf jeden fall
sind ganz klassische neonazis sag ich
mal und eben auch dieser mann also der
hippies wurde gezeigt und dieser mann
trägt diesen rudi decken heute auch mal
wieder twitter rum da steht drauf camp
auschwitz und arbeit macht frei
das ist natürlich mehr klasse von von
holocaust relativierung
holocaust-leugnung kann definitiv ja und
dann haben wir hier das bild dass du mir
geschickt die konföderierten flagge die
außerhalb also die im senat auch gern
gezeigt wurde bzw im capitol was ist das
für eine für eine symbolik für eine
bedeutung
genau das ist stefan journalisten der da
vor ort waren
der hat das foto gemacht und auch
südstaaten flagge genannt genau die
sieht man da hinten
das ist eigentlich ein symbol für das
für sklaverei steht das für rassismus
für ungleichheit steht und diese flagge
im kapitol zu sehen ist eigentlich ein
schlag ins gesicht von jedem demokraten
und jeder demokraten und das ist jetzt
nicht auf die partei bezogen weil es
eben im prinzip sklaverei unterstützt
und insbesondere geht es auch gegen
menschen die schwarz sind und auch gegen
blackwater liegen also eine schon sehr
und möchte ich nicht sagen das klingt
ein bisschen zu verharmlosen aber schon
wenn er sehr exklusive mischung aus
menschen die verschwörungs mythen
anhängen dann irgendwie überschwappen
ins rechtsextreme milieu holocaust
leugner offene rassisten menschen die
sich an ein altes system zurück wünschen
also das ist ja schon lange etwas
merkwürdige menge lage ist das etwas
klaus was du auch kennt aus seiner zeit
schon ist so in den usa korrespondent
es gibt elemente die es damals schon gab
es gibt so eine grundstimmung nicht
unter diesen extremisten über die wir
jetzt reden schon gar nicht unter den
militanten aber es gibt so eine
erhebliche gruppe der amerikaner die
sagen dieses land ist seit mindestens 30
jahren in der falschen richtung
unterwegs
vergisst seine bezüge zur religion zur
vaterland zu tradition zur weißen kultur
uns geht alles zu weit was ist seitdem
an reformen gab und das sind viele
millionen wenn es nur leute wären die
wie dieser kleinen stadt an
irgendwelchen bullshit glauben dann wäre
das kein problem
es war schon schwierig ja und wenn in
dem moment wo die vereinnahmt haben
diese diese mit zum mainstream gehören
den konservativen religiösen
patriotischen kräfte jedenfalls zu einem
erheblichen teil die dann durchaus auf
versammlungen wie gestern auch mit kind
und kegel gehen erinnert mich in der
beziehung ein bisschen an die querdenker
universalität die wir in deutschland im
moment erleben dann passiert das dass du
eine große masse husty
instrumentalisiert wird von den
extremisten und deswegen steht hinter
dem was gestern geschah eine bewegung
die in ihrer breite eine gefahr
darstellt für den bestand der demokratie
und ein großes hindernis oder eine
riesenherausforderung für die neue
administration die administration beiden
und seine strategie bisher ist mäßigung
mäßigung nicht aggressiv auftreten auf
nichts eingehen was eben zur tiefe
spaltung aller trump nur von anderen
seite führen würde und das ist ein
rezept dessen rechnung hoffentlich
aufgeht denn niemand hat ein anderes
jetzt gibt es hier bei uns in den
kommentaren viele die eine sehr bekannte
muss ich sagen verschwörungs erzählungen
verbreiten nämlich dass das gestern
überhaupt keine tram kinder gewesen sein
sondern antifa aktivisten die sich als
tramp anhänger ausgegeben haben um quasi
sein image zu schädigen man nennt das
ganze auch false flag aktionen das ist
bekannt aus geheimdienstkreisen
dort ist das tatsächlich auch eine
praxis die ist zumindest schon gab das
quasi eine aktion gestartet wurde dann
aber
einem anderen in die schuhe geschoben
wurde es ist in diesem zusammenhang also
immer mit solchen rechtsradikalen
auseinandersetzungen häufiger zu diesem
verschwörungs erzählung kommen die gibt
es auch bei uns in deutschland muss ich
sagen immer wieder julia du hast ja doch
diese bilder genauer angeguckt hast du
die leute dann auch woanders finden
können dass man jetzt wirklich sagen
kann ok man kann ausschließen dass es
zum beispiel als provokateure sind von
der polizei weil die immer wieder auf
den gleichen demonstrationen auftauchen
man muss sagen dass daher gestern
tausende menschen waren und ich das
jetzt auch von deutschland aus verfolgt
habe gleichwohl schätze ich das als eher
unwahrscheinlich ein
da ist einfach in diversen gruppen
kleber hat das jetzt gerade auch mit mit
der querdenker bewegung verglichen was
auch sinn macht weil in den quer denken
bewegungen sind wir sehr stark sind die
sehr stark auf telegramm vertreten und
da wird sich immer verabredet dazu
veranstaltungen aufgerufen und genau das
haben wir eben auch schon seit wochen
intensiv beobachten können dass das
jetzt für den 6 januar angekündigt wurde
in bestimmten gruppierung sei es jetzt
auch taler oder auf telegramm
und dass da eben von dem block beuys zum
beispiel dazu aufgerufen wurde nach
washington zu kommen und von daher mag
das vielleicht ein marginaler teilen
sein das kann ich nicht genau beurteilen
ich glaube aber nicht dass das eine
indem sie eine riesige chance fleck
aktion war das halte ich eigentlich für
ausgeschlossen also zumindest weiß ich
dass dieser mann mit den würfel haben an
denen wir gerade gesehen haben der ist
auch schon auf mehreren demonstrationen
aufgetaucht das natürlich auch sehr
markant das bild der es immer wieder am
start das heißt von team canada ist
glaube ich zumindest ausschließen eben
weil er auch so offensiv auftritt julia
vielen dank für deine recherche und für
seine erklärungen und klaus jetzt würde
ich mit dir gern nochmal darüber
sprechen wie es jetzt endlich
weitergehen kann in diesen usa also wir
haben gerade schon gehört es gibt es am
cent hebung des verfahrens bemühungen
ist ansätze ansetzen kann es mag
vielleicht kurz erklären es gibt einmal
dieses 25 management also die die
verfassung
zusatz der eingeführt wurde und es gibt
einen pietschmann verfahren was ist denn
was und was hat welche konsequenzen
beide hätten die konsequenz dass der
präsident nicht mehr präsident ist in so
dass die gemeinsamkeit dieser art
zusatzartikel 25 ist entworfen worden
nach der ermordung von john f kennedy
es hätte ja theoretisch sein können das
anders john f kennedy schwer
angeschossen im koma liegt für monate
noch am leben ist und trotzdem wäre er
weiterhin der präsident gewesen
und dann hat der senat und das kongress
der kongress gesagt wir müssen für
diesen notfall
wir waren in der mitte des kalten
krieges wo der atom koffer jeden moment
vielleicht gebraucht wird müssen wir
klare verhältnisse schaffen wer ist der
oberkommandierende und damals hat man
diesen 25 april geschrieben mit dem ziel
das so schwer wie nur möglich zu machen
aber in ganz eindeutigen fällen wie eben
in dem john f kennedy amtsunfähig und
trotzdem noch am leben
dass man dann den präsidenten wechseln
kann
zum vize präsident aber riesen er ist
mental nicht mehr fähig das anders ja
dann müsste man das uminterpretieren auf
er wäre halt nicht wegen einer
verletzung sondern wegen seiner erinnern
psychischen verfasstheit nicht mehr in
der lage das amt auszuüben
aber dann müsste das ganze kabinett
derselben ansicht sein es gibt eine
möglichkeit einen einspruch zu erheben
ist müsste durch beide kammern dass das
des kongresses durch mit riesigen
mehrheiten das illusorisch das wird
nicht passieren und im team und gab es
letztes jahr schon ist aber schon ja man
könnte ihn ganz schnell das im pitch
mitmachen verfahren machen denn die
beweise wir hatten sie ja gerade
gesendet liegen ja offen zu tage und das
ist schon verdammt nah an der
ursprünglichen formulierung für ein
engagement nämlich hochverrat und andere
gefährliche kriminelle taten
das ist nahe am hochverrat wenn der
präsident zum marsch auf das kapitol
bläst das wäre theoretisch und recht
nicht möglicherweise darstellbar
politisch wahrscheinlich undenkbar dass
man das innerhalb von 14 tagen durch
zieht der vorteil wäre
donald trump wäre ab sofort dann ein
abgesetzter präsident und nicht mehr ein
abgewählter präsident von beiden häusern
des kongresses wird die verhältnisse
klären aber
die debatte ist müßig ich werde alles
darauf dass das nicht passieren wird
jetzt gibt es hier noch eine frage zum
beispiel vorn ich muss mal kurz suchen
wie der user hieß ich hatte es mir
gemerkt wir haben viele fragen von dave
auf youtube kann man kramt nach seinem
abgang für diese gewalt setze anklagen
oder vielleicht auch für andere sachen
man kann ihn für alles mögliche anklagen
denn er ist schon hat er nicht mehr die
immunität des präsidenten
und wenn dabei kriminelle taten begangen
worden sind dann geht das mit einer ganz
normalen anklage es sei denn er würde
sich selber noch mit begnadigen
sozusagen im vorhinein umstritten ob das
geht aber es gibt ernst zu nehmende
verfassungsrechtler die das für möglich
halten dann gibt es einen riesen langen
seite sicher vor dem supreme court
ausgetragen würde und würde sich ewig
hinziehen
oder aber joe biden begnadigt
und da könnte was dafür sprechen obwohl
joe biden begnadigt trump weil er dann
das trauma traumlos wäre und
medienberater von joe biden wäre würde
ich ihnen dringend empfehlen alles zu
vermeiden was weiterhin die trump story
erzählt denn das ist das werkzeug der
mobilisierung dass dies absolut und das
hat er zur perfektion getrieben
über 70 millionen amerikaner glauben
dass er der richtige präsident wäre wenn
auch viele von denen schon wissen dass
abgewählt worden ist das ist ja nur eine
minderheit unter seinen ehemaligen
wählern aber bedauern dass das nicht
mehr ist tun die schon auch und trump
wäre weiterhin diese dominierende figur
in unserer sendung in den amerikanischen
sendungen würde jeden tag den sauerstoff
aus der luft aus der luft ziehen den joe
biden und seinem kabinett bringen
brauchen also es könnte sein das große
du hast dazu auch auf youtube welche
symbolwirkung welcher mythos wird er
gefragt er wächst aus so einem ereignis
für die antidemokratischen regung in der
zukunft in der joe biden dann amtierende
präsident ist aber diese strömungen ging
ja nicht weg ja der mythos dass eine
kraftvolle gruppe
der amerikaner kraftvoll genug um sogar
das kapitol zu stürmen weiterhin da ist
die den joe biden nicht wollen
die die wahl für einen betrug halten die
die ganzen staatlichen institutionen und
den unabhängigen medien nicht glauben
dass die weiterhin da ist und das ist
schon ein signal von durchsetzungskraft
über das man entsetzt sein kann oder
wenn man entschlossen ist diese stärke
zu nutzen
von der maz er und gibt es gerade eine
nachfrage noch zu der begnadigung von
vds kann man kurz mal zeigen hier auf
youtube dass wir auch immer euch im
blick haben während wir hier sprechen
warum kann ein krimineller begnadigt
werden mit einem nachdenklichen monti
einigt krimineller kann ja schlecht
begnadigt werden
also man muss schon kriminelle
begnadigen und das ist ein alles altes
majestät recht so begnadigungsrecht gibt
es in deutschland ja sowieso nicht das
heißt es gibt es auch aber es wird sehr
systematisch sehr verrechtlicht an
angewendet und in den usa ist das so der
letzte überbleibsel der alten britischen
kolonie ein bisschen ist der präsident
dann schon noch king man darf ohne sich
irgendwelchen rechtfertigung zu
unterziehen
einfach sagen ich mach das jetzt so und
davon hat noch niemanden so erratischen
gebrauch gemacht wie donald trump wenn
man sich anguckt wenn er schon begnadigt
hat und wer nicht begnadigt wird
überhaupt kein system erkennbar außerdem
mag ich oder in dem fall hat mich jetzt
eine internet influenza in angerufen
dass ich den begnadigen soll dann mache
ich das halt schnell und dann natürlich
das was in unmittelbar betrifft die
leute aus seiner gefolgschaft
interessantes detail donald trump kann
niemanden vor allen dingen nicht sich
selbst aber auch sonst niemanden für
etwas begnadigen was nicht nach
bundesrecht strafbar ist sondern nach
staatsrecht und cyrus vance der
generalstaatsanwalt des staates new york
wartet auf die gelegenheit die bald
kommen wird ab 12 uhr mittags am 20
januar um seine starts klagen wegen
steuerhinterziehung aller möglichen
schweigegeld zahlungen da gibt es in der
lange liste die beschäftigt eine armee
von giulianis für jahrzehnte
wenn man das abarbeitet für recht und
bedarf und da kann jumps ist weder sich
selbst noch jemand anderes begnadigen
das geht nur für bundes liegt ein
interessantes detail das finanzamt noch
wichtig werden jetzt noch mal eine
interessante frage eine fläche
detailfrage auch die aber doch viele
umtreibt gerade auch wenn sie mit
menschen zu tun haben die auch solche
dinge glauben wie donald trump
verbreitet die geht es ja auch in
deutschland thilo ich möchte wissen die
gast kann der journalismus tun um die
lügen von trump und konsorten zu kontern
was ist da dein rezept aus man braucht
zuschauer und leser und zuhörer und
deren vertrauen und das kann man sich
nur jeden tag neu verdienen mit
ehrlichem bemühen auch mit dem bemühen
zuzuhören was diejenigen sagen die einem
nicht zuhören wollen um dann nach
möglichkeit darauf einzugehen den dialog
aufrechterhalten und mit fakten arbeiten
es gibt unerreichbare vielleicht sind
das 10 15 prozent das könnte sein dass
es so viele sind manche medien
wissenschaftler rechnen mit solchen
zahlen oder gesellschaftswissenschaftler
aber das sind immer noch die 85 prozent
und auch und wir beide werden jetzt
skeptisch beurteilt und ich jetzt mit
meinen doch ziemlich harten handkanten
schlägen gegen camp nach dem gestrigen
tag auf werden nicht nur freunde
gewinnen aber solange ich argumentiere
und sage das ist meine auffassung und
die fakten auf die ich mich stütze
belegen kann wenn ich gefragt werde
solange hoffe ich dass menschen
vertrauen haben zu dem handwerk dass wir
beide aus führen und versuchen sauber zu
machen
auch wir rutschen ab und zu mal übers
ziel hinaus oder treten mal daneben
aber wir versuchen uns zu bessern und
unser ziel ist die wahrheitsgetreue
berichterstattung noch nie keiner von
uns beiden ist sie morgens ins büro
gekommen und zu sagen ich will die leute
davon überzeugen dass das und das so ist
obwohl ich weiß dass es so nicht und das
muss auch so spiele habe das war eine
schande dass manchmal auch tatsächlich
so glaub ich hab das manchmal das gefühl
dass er wirklich das glaubt was er
erzählt ich glaube die intensität der
aufbringt kannst du nicht aufbringen
wenn du die behauptungen von der
von der gestohlenen wahl zum beispiel
nicht selber glauben würdest er glaubt
dass es ist teil seiner psychischen
verfasstheit
dann hoffe ich mal dass wir euch heute
hier gut informiert haben
wahrheitsgetreu berichtet haben ich sehe
natürlich die kommentare von euch die
auch kritisch sind die sich beschweren
oder beklagen das gehört mit dazu wir
nehmen sie wahr wir nehmen sie mit also
es geht uns auch nicht einfach so vor
über die reden da auch darüber werden
wir nicht von der kamera stehen und
versuchen überlegen wie wir das anders
und besser machen können deswegen ja
auch der dialog mit euch hier in den
sendungen aber für heute sage ich erst
mal vielen dank fürs zu sehen fürs
mitdiskutieren fragen stellen und bis
zum nächsten mal macht gut
[Musik]